welcome back so we're talking about turbulent
flows and today should be a pretty fun lecture
so i'm going to walk you through a lot
of examples of turbulence and just great
movies and visualizations of turbulent flows why
they're important how we can use them as engineers
and i'll provide you with some open
source resources codes and databases
in case you're interested in getting started
doing research in this field so i'm pretty
excited about this one i think this is going
to be a lot of fun and one of the things i love
about fluid dynamics and turbulence in particular
is all of the great movies and visualizations um
so that that's going to be kind of
fun here in fact i'll share with you
um the the reason i got into fluid dynamics
in the first place at least i joke this i
used to do more pure math i was sitting
in a in a restaurant with my wife
drinking a bowl of miso soup and i was looking at
the patterns uh kind of you know churning patterns
of this this bowl of miso soup and i thought boy
this is more interesting than you know anything
i'm working on right now so i'm going to go
study that so you know this kind of beautiful
visually appealing movie nature of it i think
is cool so we're going to have a lot of that in
this lecture before i start i want to um bring up
this quote by feynman from the feynman lectures
that has always stuck with me and i don't expect
you to read all of this um but i'll i'll kind of
walk you through it so the test of science is its
ability to predict had you never visited the earth
could you predict the thunderstorms the volcanoes
the ocean waves the auroras the colorful sunset
this is really a statement that even though
we know the navy or stokes equations even
though i can write down the equations of fluid
flows and i can simulate them in a computer
it is very hard for us humans to know before
seeing a phenomena whether it exists or whether
it's possible and that's one of the things that's
intriguing about physics and fluid dynamics in
general is there's a huge disconnect from our
equations to all of the richness of reality okay
there's another great one here the next great era
of awakening of human intellect may well produce a
method of understanding the qualitative content
of equations for example if i just gave you the
navier-stokes equations could you from just
the equations know that there are hurricanes
not today maybe that's the next great
awakening anyway i love this quote
so what we do is we try to understand the
complexity of the world through analogies
through examples of simpler building block flows
that we might be able to understand so i've walked
you through this a little bit in the previous
lecture there are lots of canonical example flows
and i'm going to go into every you know each
of these with a lot more detail in this lecture
we're going to watch movies and walk through uh
different key aspects of why they're interesting
challenging and important so again wake flows
very important for engineering mixing layers you
know this comes up everywhere you'll see this in
the cloud sometimes if you look carefully enough
jets you know very impactful we live you know
in the jet age okay so i'm going to walk through
lots of these examples kind of one by one
and i want to remind you of course that we
ultimately want to deal with these very very
complex systems we're going to analyze them by
constituent parts by these building block pieces
uh and eventually we might want to do something
like modeling or controlling these systems but
we have to understand the building blocks first
okay good so pipe flow a lot of this i
already told you in the previous lecture
a lot of history of fluid dynamics goes back
to pipe flows pumping water through cities
and so pipe flow is still very
important today there's a really cool
video a lot of these come from the aps
division of fluid dynamics conference
and so you can find these and watch the
whole videos i'm just showing excerpts
where here they took a pipe and they have these
four fans that they can accelerate uh flow through
the pipe to try to control the turbulence to
try to make it more laminar to change the drag
of the fluid going through this pipe so you
see upstream downstream here's the perturbed
section and at some point they're going to
turn on this controller here and they're going
to with the perturbation change the nature
of the downstream so just by by increasing
some property here with these fans they are making
the downstream much more laminar and presumably
this has better profile for things like drag okay
so this is a really cool example of a canonical
flow that has been extremely well studied there
are great researchers who have spent most of their
career studying this one canonical flow example
its stability its mathematical properties its
engineering properties good wake flows again
wake flows are super um ubiquitous everywhere
and it's one of the first flows that we deal
with uh at least as computational engineers
often we'll start by modeling something like this
the flow past a cylinder at low reynolds number
and of course we're trying to use this
as an analog for more complex wake flows
like the wake behind a transport truck
or a boat or a plane this is a turbulent
wake um that was collected experimentally by my
collaborator richard zeeman at tu braunschweig
so wake flows are everywhere very important if
you can control the wake uh more efficiently
even a little bit you will save billions
uh tens hundreds of billions of dollars
annually just by reducing the
drag uh behind transport vehicles
okay uh i couldn't help this is a pretty cool
work i couldn't help but include this work
where uh these researchers at imperial college
london are actually analyzing the wakes behind
fractal geometries so i showed you you know
the wake behind a cylinder or a d-shaped body
in this work they're looking at sorry skipped
ahead in this work they're looking at um
the wake behind you know a square a circle
and then a fractal object and i think this
is super interesting there are different drag
profiles and mixing and turbulence uh that you
can get with these fractal cross-section
wakes and so this is just a really cool uh
avenue of work looking at these things they
actually do this experimentally which i think
is incredibly impressive uh to get this kind
of um this kind of result so okay good other
examples where wake flows are important uh
of course when you're flying commercially
these large large commercial transport jets will
create massive wakes behind them you see this huge
vorticity uh generated by by the tip vortex from
the wing this actually has huge impact for error
port scheduling when a you know triple 7 or a 747
takes off or lands they have to wait for minutes
before a smaller aircraft can take off afterwards
because that vorticity is so large it could flip
a smaller jet and things like this have happened
there have been accidents because of wake
vorticity so understanding and characterizing and
control like mitigating this could have you know
it could make it so that you take off faster and
you can have more uh aircraft density at airports
good other examples the boundary layer is
one of the most important flows so this is an
experiment i'm going to rewind just so you see
this the experimental setup so boundary layers
essentially model if you have a flat plate
like let's think of the surface of a wing
how does the flow become turbulent and more and
more complex as it accelerates you know over that
wing and so this is great work that i'm going to
again pull this video from the aps fluid gallery
where they have experimentally characterized they
experimentally accelerate this this plate through
the water and you can see that as kind of the
flow velocity or the reynolds number gets higher
the turbulence gets more and more complex and more
and the boundary layer also gets thicker and so
this has implications for the drag on that surface
whether or not the flow will separate which
has huge impacts for lift as well and these are
extremely important quantities to know and to be
able to predict when you're designing an aircraft
wing are the mixing and the drag and whether or
not the flow is going to separate because those
are all critical for safety and for efficiency
i like this next video because they're going to
put the low velocity and high velocity on top of
each other so this is slow and fast and you can
see the change in the nature of the turbulence
just by accelerating the flow to
higher reynolds numbers so here it's
much much more turbulent but it's also more
uniform okay so that again has pretty big
implications again you can watch this whole video
if you just go through these links now that was
experimentally acquired we also have the ability
with high performance computing to simulate these
boundary layers with exquisite detail numerically
so to track every minor eddy and horseshoe
vortex across this entire boundary layer at
relatively high reynolds numbers so this is
a johns hopkins dataset turbulent boundary layer i
think in the previous video i showed you one from
kth but really you can do pretty amazing things
to probe to probe these flows and get a really
high resolution picture now what's difficult in
simulations that's easy in experiments is getting
really long time series to simulate this flow one
snapshot might be you know hundreds of megabytes
or gigabytes or tens or hundreds of gigabytes
and you know simulating a short run might take
you know half a million cpu hours or more i mean
i don't know off the top of my head it's a lot
we but you can get exquisite 3d detail across
all of the scales whereas in experiments it's
much harder to get the full you know
detailed view in space and in time
but you can run that experiment for hours and
hours and hours and collect statistics of what's
happening for very very long time series so just
in case you're you're curious like experiments and
simulations are kind of complementary there are
things that simulations can do that experiments
can't and vice versa so they're really really
important to have both of these perspectives okay
uh cavity flows i think are super fun so
a cavity basically is a notch or an empty
space where you have flow going over it and
these flows are super interesting so you have
a sheer layer that's forming here and there are
cavity resonances here that are interacting with
that shear layer and if you if the flow is fast
enough you start getting acoustic radiation into
the far field and acoustic radiation inside the
cavity and it turns out cavity flows are really
important because if you turn this cavity upside
down it starts to look like the bombay doors of a
of an aircraft and so i have a video i took from
chicagoland skydiving center so the bombay doors
are opening okay now the inside of this airplane
is a cavity it's resonating there's recirculating
flow it's acoustics are loud in this case they're
not dropping bombs they're dropping people but in
any case the vibrations and the unsteady fluid
mechanics from that cavity flow can create huge
acoustic vibrations inside of this cavity which
in some cases might even damage what's inside
of there if you have you know ordinance inside
of there they could be vibrating and banging
together and stuff and so understanding modeling
and controlling cavity flows is a really important
area of fluid dynamics actually this is one
of the the projects that my phd advisor clancy
rowley worked on early in his career and made
some really really key advances in modeling and
understanding and controlling these cavity flows
in the compressible regime super impressive work
okay i'm just going to keep going because i
absolutely love these videos i love canonical
flows like this is what i would do in my spare
time you know on a saturday morning is just check
out a jet okay so this jet is absolutely beautiful
you can again see this multi-scale unsteady
nature of this thing and there's a lot of
flavors of jets this is one of the harder
uh canonical problems because the jets that we
care about out of you know actual jet engines at
uh subsonic transonic and supersonic speeds are
very complicated they're typically compressible so
uh you know you have density variations you get
acoustic radiation uh so acoustic uh energy is
being you know scattered off of this turbulent
wake and it's just a very very complex multi-scale
uh three-dimensional flow lots of great people
work on jets and it's one of the kind of
hardest and most interesting and very
important problems again jet noise
directly affects tens of millions of humans
on earth right so just within the the heathrow
flight path alone or in the greater uh manhattan
or new york metropolitan area or los angeles
there are tons of people whose lives are directly
affected by the noise that's radiated from jets
carrying humans and cargo from one place to the
other and so a better ability to model and control
and suppress that jet noise would have a direct
uh benefit in in human lives i mean one of the
reasons the concord wasn't successful was because
it was so loud okay and it wasn't jet noise
in that case but you know noise is a big problem
people can only handle so much jet noise okay good
now mixing layers i really like mixing layers
because this is actually from a dynamical
system from a mathematical standpoint mixing
layers is one of the most interesting kind of
to study and to analyze from a stability
and dynamical systems point of view so you
can imagine uh following a packet of fluid as it
evolves along this this mixing layer and seeing
kind of what bifurcations occur because here it's
very linear and periodic uh unstable instability
then you get vortex pairing this is the kelvin uh
kelvin vortex shedding you get this vortex pairing
where the frequency halves so it's lower frequency
and then you get this vortex breakdown to chaotic
kind of turbulent regime in the wake so very
very interesting stuff happening here i reallylike mixing layers
I've shown you all ofthese canonical flows,  now i want to show you areally really complex flow
To kind of motivate whyyou might actually want all of those constituentpieces to understand them
because in a real flowyou're going to see all of those pieces.
Again, this is a really really cool simulation by the KTHgroup... just fantastic fluids researchers
and i'llactually talk about the code they use to generatethis in a little bit
but this is the flow overa wing cross section, so supposed to be
a piece of this larger aircraft
and this is a full direct numerical simulation sothey're not approximating anything
they're modeling all of the scales from biggest scaleto smallest scale of the entire Navier-Stokesequations
this is a tour de force in
modeling to do this direct numerical simulation.
And so they build this computational domainover this airfoil and soon you're gonna see just
this incredible complexity of the turbulence
evolving and i'll walk you through how it
relates to some of those canonical flows okay
so you know and they're very careful they have
to be very careful about how they set up the
computational domain the boundary conditions
uh how many meshes 35 million core hours
75 terabytes of data for the simulation
And here is what it leads up to. I
love this, this is one of my favorites.
so they've tripped the flow to
turbulence here with a body force
and you can just see this incrediblemulti-scale complexity evolvingin the boundary layer
So this is the boundarylayer flow over the flat or smooth partof this this airfoil
so they have this incredibleboundary layer with the the hairpin head vortices
and the multiscale developing and thickening of
the boundary layer at the trailing edge you'll see
trailing edges are usually characterized by mixing
layers because remember Bernoulli you have faster
flow over the top slower flow over the bottom
when the fast flow impinges it creates this mixing
layer type flow right in the near wake formation
of a mixing layer and then as you zoom out and
start to go to larger larger wake scales you start
to see the formation of actual uh wake structures
just like those bluff body flows and so that's
really cool in this one flow alone you have three
kind of different canonical flows all interacting
and working together you have your boundary layer
flow on the surface, your mixing layer in the near
wake, and then you have the kind of Karman vortex
street type wake behavior in the far awake and
all of this is important to understand and to be
able to model and predict and control when you
want to design and control in real aerospace
applications so very cool and this is really kind
of the state of the art of what's possible
Maybe this was five years ago so five years
later maybe we can simulate a little bit higher
Reynolds number a little bit more complicated but this is pretty impressive
okay good uh so i think i've walked through
some of my favorite canonical flows and
hopefully convinced you that these actually are
important they're challenging and they culminate
when you put them together you can
start to describe really complex flows
now i'm going to walk through some of the open
resources that are available so that you can get
working in this really really
exciting and important field
so one of the ones i use almost all the time is
the johns hopkins turbulence database databases
there's multiple databases this is such a valuable
resource in the fluids community um they have tons
of different examples from isotropic turbulence
channel flows uh magnetohydrodynamics they have
you know transitional boundary layers this is
an extremely well thought of well-curated rich
turbulent data set set of data sets where you can
download this data and start computing things and
working on these flows yourself this is especially
useful for those of us who do data-driven methods
and machine learning you know extracting coherent
structures and patterns and trying to build models
this is a playground of data now i will warn you
some of these things are pretty hard to download
they're pretty big and so that can uh that can get
expensive fast and uh just giving you one example
this is a video of a visualization of a flow from
this turbulence data set so there in this case um
looking at the multi-scale nature that every time
you zoom into a vortex filament you're going to
see more scales of vortex filaments and it's just
really cool like you can download this and play
around with this yourself visualize analyze these
flows so we're going to zoom into this packet here
and look there's more filaments inside so it's
truly a multi-scale turbulent data database
okay good there are lots of others i'll try to put
links in the um in the comments and you know in
a lot of our papers we have other resources so
um there is a data set called hi-com h-y-c-o-m
where you can download atmospheric sorry not
atmospheric sea surface ocean current data
for the entire globe you can get you know the flow
field in the gulf of mexico from satellite imaging
for decades at hourly resolution it's incredible
you can um download the sea surface temperature on
the entire surface of the earth with incredible
resolution in space and time so noaa and nasa
have also released just absolutely phenomenal
databases for atmospheric and geophysical flows
stanford has their own set of databases
so really lots of good resources out there
codes let's say you want to generate this data so
downloading data is one thing but if you want to
do control if you want to do modeling if you want
to do predictions sometimes you need to actually
have the code to generate data dynamically okay so
databases are what my colleague barrett noak would
call postmortem data analysis sometimes we want
to analyze the living data in an actual simulation
one of my favorites and the one that i use all the
time is this immersed boundary projection method
it's a really quick easy way to simulate
laminar flows this is based on an algorithm by
tyra and colonias and colonia centaira really
cool immersed boundary projection method
and this code is on github by clancy rowley so
he developed this ibpm in c plus very modular
very easy to um to modify to make the the objects
move to add control uh to take the navy or stokes
equations and to analyze individual components
of those equations you know pull out the linear
component pull out the diffusion term things
like that so really kind of uh easy entry point
to simulating at least you know these kind
of cool laminar flows but moving geometries
another ubiquitous piece of software
is open foam lots and lots of people
use open foam and you can simulate very very
complex geometries three-dimensional flows
add in turbulence models i mean this
is a pretty sophisticated package
one of the ones that my lab likes a lot and you
know my collaborators use a lot is this neck 5000
code that is supported by argonne national labs
anl.gov and so you can download everything here
it's completely open and very well maintained by
the government this has kind of a long memory so
this is going to be maintained for a long time
and again uh that flow i showed you by the kth
group this wing flow this was simulated in
neck 5000 to the best of my knowledge and
so this is like a real research production
code where you can go as complex as you want
parallelize i mean this is is heavy duty stuff and
i know that my students and my collaborators use
this a lot so very very cool cool code okay good
so hopefully i've convinced you that flows are
just interesting really multi-scale there's
kind of these canonical example flows but real
flows have bits and pieces of all of them working
together and you can actually start simulating and
getting your hands dirty with data and with codes
yourself so i highly encourage you to do that
and stay tuned we're going to have more kind of
in this general turbulence and fluid dynamics
machine learning for fluid dynamics so i'm really
excited to see where this all goes thank you